حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل في اللي كان السبب
حسبي الله وعم الوكيل حرمني منك يابا انت
ضو عيوني وضلك ضو عيون الله يرحمك ويحسن
اليك عند النبيين والصديقين والشهداء وحوض
النبي يا ار يا
رب الله يرحمك يا الله يسهل عليك يا الله
يسهل عليك يا الله يسهل عليك الحمد لله
الحمدلله جيت خشيت الدار لقيت اولادي بده
نام على سريري مت يا بابا خليني انام على
السرير انتم تعالوا ناموا زي كل مره في
الصاله جنبي قال لا يا اب انا ننام على
السرير قلت خلص يا بنام وانتم على السرير
انا خليني انام بره في الصاله ناموا الحم
تعشوا وناموا الحمد لله ما فجاه الا هيك
الساعه ما لقيت الا كل الدار واقع علينا
على السرير طاق من النوم زوجتي والاربعه
نايمين جنبها راح بسام ولا سلم لي الثلاثه
قبل ما اروح سته سته اعطته فطاير الي لهم
كلوهم هم مش ي بسم شل عن تمه يا ناس والله
شل عن تمه عشان يطعم من اياها لما روح
بيقولي يا با شلتها عن تمي عشانك والله
شلتها عن تمي على شانك قت له خلص يا بابا
انت الحين نام يا بابا عشان سكريات نفطر
فيها الصبح ي الصبح يا ناس راح بسم عند
ربه وانا
لحالي الحمد لله على كل حال الحمد لله
وحسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل